[Musique]
voici les premières images de l'arsenal
trouvée par les policiers dans la
voiture du forcené de béziers malgré les
barrages son complice court toujours
question les armes de guerre ont-elles
fait leur apparition dans les cités des
éléments de réponse dans un instant
première journée test pour les couloirs
de bus fermés à paris on craignait la
pagaille apparemment les motions sont
restées limitées trois questions ce soir
à bertrand delanoë le maire de paris
bonsoir monsieur le maire il ya tout à
l'heure la sphère des anticholestérols
témoignages inédits sur les méthodes de
bailleurs le laboratoire allemand a
multiplié cadeaux et pression sur les
médecins pour les inciter à prescrire le
médicament aujourd'hui retirée on
l'appelait le petit prince patrice
martin enfant prodige du ski nautique
qui a tout gagné pendant plus de 20 ans
arrête la compétition informations
france 2 elle est confirmée par
l'intéressé nous l'entendons bonsoir à
tous et merci de votre attention
direction béziers pour commencer presque
deux jours après la fusillade qui a fait
un mort
ce sont des actes de guerre comme en
palestine ou en ex yougoslavie voilà ce
que déclare ce soir le maire de la ville
raymond couderc les policiers
recherchent le complice et s'interroge
sur le mobile de ce coup de folie sur
place léo lamberto fin de cette émission
je vous en rappelle le principal titre
la mise à jour de l'arsenal trouvée par
les policiers dans la voiture du forcené
de béziers malgré les barrages son
complice court toujours
on s'interroge sur l'apparition d'armes
de guerre dans les cités à suivre la
météo patrice drevet prochain
rendez-vous et l'info minuit dernier
journal présenté par laurence piquet a
signé 2
7h40 françoise laborde recevra dans les
4 vérités josé rossi en duplex d'ajaccio
vous retrouverez à 13 heures daniel
bilalian je vous retrouverai pour ma
part avec beaucoup de plaisir tous les
soirs à 20h jusqu'à jeudi
à demain
[Musique]